okay so let's start with a very bizarre
press conference that Donald Trump gave
where he did all sorts of things that
make very little sense and what I want
to point out about this press conference
in particular is that Donald Trump seems
barely conscious in this press
conference so the bone white eyes in the
middle of an orange face his eyes
half-closed he sounds like he's on
ambien or Downers barely awake and
reminder this is a clip of a press
conference about kovat 19 and the death
of a patient and Trump is rambling
incoherently about Isis slurring
sniffing short of breath take a look and
listen at this first clip from this
bizarre press conference again it's been
it's been a long journey in Afghanistan
in particular it's been a very long
journey it's been a it's been a hard
journey for everybody we're very largely
a law-enforcement group and that's not
what our soldiers are all about their
fighters are the greatest fighters in
the world as you know we've destroyed in
Syria and Iraq 100% of the Isis
Caliphate 100% we have thousands of
prisoners we've killed Isis fighters by
the thousands
the labored breathing combined with his
barely awake voice and rambling about
Isis it's all very weird then here's
Trump strangely talking about the
sacrifices that have been made in
Afghanistan and he comes apart talking
about the expenditure of treasure the
expenditure of treasury in the fight
again what on earth is this guy talking
about seemingly soon ambulant I guess
most of all I want to thank all of the
people in the United States for having
spent so much in terms of blood in terms
of treasure
and Treasury the money that has been
spent the lives that have been lost and
we just signed an agreement that puts us
in a position to get it done bring us
down to in the vicinity of 8,000 troops
the United Nations was informed of
everything and NATO has been great
secretary Stoltenberg has been fantastic
again the extremely slow speech the
labored breathing the sniffing and not
making one iota of sense then in comes
Mike Pence who is remember he's running
this whole thing we'll follow up on that
component as well and says Travel is
being banned to Iran and watch Trump in
the background seeming like he's
struggling to stay awake the task force
met this morning and brought the
president a range of options and at his
direction we will be doing the following
first the president authorized action
today to add additional travel
restrictions on Iran we will be using
section 212 °f on banning travel from
Iran Iran is also already under a travel
ban but we are expanding existing travel
restrictions to include any foreign
national who has visited Iran within the
last fourteen days and then a key moment
Donald Trump asked about you've been
referring to all of this as a hoax now
someone has died do you stand by that
and Trump incomprehensibly says no what
I meant was that the hoax is on them on
the Democrats with kovat 19 what the
other day in the Cabinet Room with
African American leaders you've got to
get away from politics
I you were down in Charleston last night
using the word host when talking about
Democrats somebody now is dead from this
do you regret that
no no hooks referring to the action that
they take to try and pin this on
somebody because we've done such a good
job the hoax is on them not I'm not
talking about what's happening here I'm
talking what they're doing that's the
hoax that's just a continuation of the
hoax whether it's the impeachment hoax
or the Russia Russia Russia hope this is
what I'm talking about
I challenge anyone to explain what Trump
means here when he called it a hoax he
met the hoax is on the Democrats but
it's also being perpetrated by the
Democrats then the Democrats are hoaxing
and being hoaxed
but kovat 19 itself is not the hoax
imagine that and then lastly here back
to the topic of Afghanistan Trump in
this part gets visibly confused he says
we never should have gone into
Afghanistan under Obama of course we
went in before Barack Obama Trump seems
to realize it immediately gets confused
and says actually we should have gone in
it becomes a complete and total mess you
pride yourself on a dealmaker but your
former national security adviser john
bolton he said this is an obama style
deal and sent the wrong message to Isis
and al Qaeda what did the Taliban give
up here will you be hosting the Taliban
in Washington to Camp David or will you
meet them abroad well look at that look
nobody should be criticizing this deal
after 19 years he had his chance he
didn't do it he was very much in favor
of going in we should have never gone in
in the first place when they went into
when when they went into Iraq listen
listen when they went into Iraq when
they went into the Middle East in such a
fashion I was very much against it
shouldn't a gun gun and he thought we
should have that's been proven wrong I'm
surprised that anybody would be against
something where we try and end a 19 year
of war were 8,000 miles away from our
home we've done a great job in the sense
that we've killed a lot of terrorists
we've put him out of commission so then
he actually says well no I don't mean it
was bad for Obama to go into Afghanistan
I mean Bush shouldn't have gone into
Iraq I was against it that's a lied from
went on Howard
and said he was in favor but this is
actually all about Afghanistan anyway so
Obama's opinion or Trump's opinion about
Bush's Iraq war it has nothing to do
with what Donald Trump is doing in
Afghanistan it is nonsensical rambling I
got an email over the weekend from
someone who said David we see this guy
as an ignorant clown but a lot of his
followers see this same press conference
and they see strength and power and a
guy who's not going to be manipulated by
the libs and that's probably true that a
lot of Trumpets see this same press
conference that way and that's why we
can't convince them to vote for someone
other than Trump in November we simply
have to go around them Donald Trump had
a rally in the Super Tuesday state of
North Carolina and he went into a
bizarre diatribe because of a
potentially Mexican audience member and
in the video you're going to see Donald
Trump point to someone in the audience
and start to say he's Mexican and then
he says but wait are you Mexican no way
you're Mexican you are you aren't no way
that guy is Mexican he's as Mexican as I
am it's genuinely hard to tell whether
Donald Trump is shocked that there might
really be a Mexican person at one of his
rallies maybe it's a light-skinned
Mexican which Donald Trump might not
know exists Donald Trump not
particularly familiar with Central and
South America I don't know what's going
on here but it is very very weird the
dome where do you live like this guy
he's a Mexican you're about as Mexican
as I am look at this guy he's as Mexican
as I am look at that hat are you Mexican
are you Mexican no you're not are you
he is it's like Elizabeth Warren she
said she was an Indian I said right
I said I have more Indian blood in me
than you have and I have none and she
said oh this is terrible so she went out
and got a test and it turned out not so
good for her right extremely strange and
of course has to throw in Elizabeth
Warren Indian references as well can you
guys believe that this is the world that
we're in today that this is what we're
living in in 2020 the president ranting
and raving about a possibly Mexican
audience member is it notable this of
course is upper Trump as we discussed
yesterday with psychiatrist dr. Justin
Frank this reminds me of when Donald
Trump spotted a black guy in the
audience and started to yell about my
african-american remember this abortive
rally from the campaign we had a case
where we had an african-american guy who
is a fan of mine great fan great guy in
fact I want to find out what's going on
with him you know what I look at my
african-american over here look at him
are you the greatest do you know what
I'm talking about okay so we have an
african-american guy at one of the
rallies a month ago this is sort of a
concept for rally material Trump used to
just read poll numbers totally out of
context at rallies a new direction to go
would be evaluate the perceived Wraiths
inocent ethnicity of people in the crowd
maybe turn it into some kind of game
show because that's effectively what
we're dealing with right now and then of
course we got to the moment in the rally
when Donald Trump glitched glitching
this time specifically on the word
banker you'll hear it if you're watching
you'll also see that shoulder spasm that
we discussed yesterday with psychiatrist
dr. Justin Frank talked about that
phenomenon that is often notable with
Trump take a look so they don't have to
go back to the evil banker and borrow
money from the banker and lose the farm
lose the business it won't happen and I
always say it because you know I know a
lot of parents
another day another glitch and then
lastly this is almost satirical at this
point Trump bragged about yesterday's of
the day before yesterday's large
increase in the stock market ignoring of
course that it was an erratic
rebound from last week's fastest ten
percent decline in the stock market in
history which Trump blamed on the
democratic debate then here is Trump
taking credit for the erratic rebound
day that the stock market had this is an
incredible time for our nation our
country is stronger than ever before and
today we just had the largest one-day
increase in the stock market in history
imagine cheering for that the fastest
10% decrease ever the week before you
get a partial rebound followed by the
way yesterday with another thousand
point loss and Trump has the crowd
cheering about the one day in the
interlude of erratic stock market
insanity and they're just cheering and
absolutely loving it and then by the way
here's Trump yesterday yesterday the
stock market crashed again Trump asked
about it he says oh no I have it I
haven't seen the numbers I'm focused on
this the country's in great shape the
markets in great shape I'm focused on
this this is very important what luck
right Trump only has the availability
and the time in his schedule to follow
the stock market on days where the stock
market is up amazing coincidence so
anyway another Trump rally filled with
what you would expect to hear from the
senile guys that go to your local
watering hole at 10:30 p.m. on a Tuesday
night more so than what would be suited
for a presidential rally and a President
of the United States this is where we
are in 2020 the way the primary is going
we may be in this situation until
January of 2025 as utterly insane as
that sounds
Trump would be what 78 at that point in
time this is scary stuff and I'm worried
that that's the direction in which we
are going we've previously talked about
Donald Trump's anti-vaccine tendencies
and some video from yesterday reveals
that it actually seems Donald Trump
doesn't even understand vaccine
Nations Trump had the summit with a
bunch of different medical experts and
pharmaceutical CEOs that are working on
vaccines and treatments for the virus
outbreak that we're currently dealing
with I have to refer to it that way to
avoid being demonetised on YouTube I'll
tell you about that later this week but
we'll just call it the virus outbreak
and dr. Leonard Schleifer from Regeneron
pharma is talking to Trump in this clip
we're about to watch and Trump is just
asking the most uninformed questions
that sound like what a first or second
grader would ask the first time they're
learning about how medicine and
vaccinations work take a look and also
it will put it in a different way make
you better quicker well think of it this
way if you if you get immunized with one
of these vaccines you're gonna make some
antibodies to protect you we're gonna
already make those antibodies and give
them to you so you don't have to go
through that whole process does anybody
think that talking to Trump about
antibodies is going to clear up his
perspective on what it is that's going
on and then this is the big shocker
Trump starts to get the idea that the
flu vaccine could be given to people to
protect them from kovat 19 which is just
shocking that a wealthy educated 70 year
old man thinks that a vaccine for the
flu would maybe work on this and Trump
has been going around for two weeks now
comparing this to the flu he knows that
these are two different things
but he says don't you think if we gave
people a solid flu vaccine maybe it
would help people with quote corona and
the doctors in the room say no mr.
president that would not work you take a
solid flu vaccine you don't think that
would have an impact or much of an
impact
Korona no no what about the chickenpox
vaccine maybe that would help deal with
the corona guys he thinks windmills
cause cancer of course he doesn't
understand vaccines or anything else and
what this actually does is it sheds
light onto his anti vaccine tendencies
the anti vaccine crowd when Trump during
the debates sort of placated the
anti-vaccine movement with some of the
things he said the anti-vaccine movement
actually thought hey maybe this guy is
one of us when Trump invited Bobby
Kennedy jr. an anti vaccine advocate
vaccine skeptic maybe better said to
Trump Tower during the transition period
to talk about some vaccine Commission or
whatever I don't even know that it ever
got put together the anti vaccine of us
it turns out Trump doesn't even really
understands how vaccines ostensibly work
never mind does he have an understanding
of the arguments made by the anti
vaccine 'ti he just has no idea and it's
just sort of like sure anti-vaxxer yeah
I'm and meet with me and you can see the
look on his face when you watch these
videos he's having trouble even remotely
following the conversation that's taking
place in the room never mind
understanding what the president should
understand in a situation like the one
he's faced with and and when I saw this
video it's shocking and it's it's
visually stunning to see a president so
clueless and in so over his head but at
the same time it's really demoralizing
because this is a problem we're trying
to deal with and you know it but it's
Trump next going to suggest let's spray
people with Lysol to either protect them
or ourselves it's actually worse than a
dystopian reality because it's a
flat-out idiocracy and as the numbers
continue to get worse and the
administration seems clueless having a
guy who prays about disease running the
entire thing having a guy who doesn't
even understand vaccines meeting with
pharmaceutical companies I am NOT
optimistic about the u.s. the White
House's role in all of this what I'm
hoping for is that
other countries as well as agencies and
organizations in the u.s. that are
working relatively independent of the
control of the White House will be able
to make some progress and make some
things happen here it was a completely
vile weekend of disinformation and
propaganda from the president and he
also had another one of these helicopter
press press conferences where he's
yelling at the cameras while the
helicopter whirs in the background and
this time he said in his defense of his
handling of kovat 19 he says listen a
lot more people have died from the flu
at the time he said no one had died yet
that changed just hours after this press
conference we'll get to that momentarily
but most bizarrely Donald Trump claimed
as the helicopter word in the background
that the government is ordering elements
of medical now you might be saying well
the elements of medical what David it
sounds like there's a word missing there
no just elements of medical take a look
this tremendous spirit a lot of spirit
and as you know with the flu
on average we lose from 26,000 to 78,000
people here even more than that and some
some cases some years we haven't lost
anybody yet and hopefully we can keep
that intact we there have been no deaths
in the United States at all a lot of
that's attributable to the fact that we
close the border very early otherwise it
could be a different story so we'll
we'll just keep doing a good job we're
ordering a lot of supplies we're
ordering a lot of a lot of elements and
frankly we wouldn't be ordering unless
it was something like this but we're
ordering a lot of different elements of
medical we are working on cures and
we're getting some very good results
does he mean elements like they're
ordering elements from the periodic
table like cesium and barium that he
thinks have medical uses this is how you
know as if we didn't before that Trump
has no idea what's going on we're
ordering elements of medical he might as
well say we're ordering
widgets and ding-dongs it'sit'sit's
communicating as much value and meaning
what he is saying is how much how much
we would get if he said we're ordering
ding-dongs
elements of medical has about the same
amount of meaning and this guy is in so
far over his head
that it almost exceeds the English
language's ability to describe it it's
blathering it's lies it's nonsense
there's almost Trump is almost existing
in the event imagine a Venn diagram
where you have Ronald Reagan's cognitive
decline which is not a joke it's nothing
to laugh at it's it's horrible George
Bush's and competence with the added
element of Donald Trump's extreme
weaponized narcissism the Venn diagram
of those three is where Donald Trump is
operating and lastly by the way if kovat
19 is overblown trumped up by Dems all
under control
why would Trump even be ordering
so-called elements of medical that they
wouldn't normally order it doesn't
really make sense for something that's
perfectly under control to take action
that is out of the ordinary it probably
doesn't matter
it's all merely uninformed propaganda
and then to close up this insane copter
press conference before going to the
next one Trump also again was asked
about the stock market implosion and he
keeps blaming it on Democrats instead of
the growing global pandemic which Trump
is not particularly inspiring conference
on confidence on
well I think it's just people don't know
let's see unknown you know they look at
it and they say how long will this last
I think they're not very happy with the
Democrat candidates when they see them I
think that has an impact yeah world
markets are crashing as the outbreak
spreads because people are just really
upset with the Democratic candidates it
was a very gruesome Super Tuesday for
the progressive movement in the United
States one of the things I do not do on
this program I will not do on this
program is give you unrealistic
assessments of how things are going and
I told you yesterday the momentum for
Joe Biden from his over performing in
South Carolina
combined with the drop out and
endorsements of Pete Budaj edge and Amy
Klobuchar it is likely to propel Biden
to better results than the polling
reflects going in to yesterday's
elections and this indeed happened it
was a bad night for Bernie Sanders it
was about as good of a night as Joe
Biden could have hoped to have given
where he was just a week ago
even winning in Texas was Joe Biden
which he was not expected to win so
we're going to look at the results we're
going to look at how the results
compared with the polls we'll look at
the delegate numbers we'll analyse the
path forward but what is really
important to understand bigger picture
about what's going on here
is that this has been a similar pattern
in the last several Democratic primaries
where we're going to look at this
tomorrow in 2008 and in 2016 you have a
situation where you have the polling at
the beginning of the primary and then
things start to drastically shift either
to candidates getting very very far
apart and then it reverses or to
candidates getting very very close and
then it reverses look at 2008 and look
at 2016 and look in 10 days at 2020 and
you will see a very similar pattern and
again being surprised when the same
patterns repeat themselves means we're
not paying attention we are being adults
here we are going to deal with what is
and not what we would like to be
let's start with the results there were
14 primaries yesterday plus American
Samoa Joe Biden won nine of the
primaries Bernie won four and they're
still counting in Maine which is very
close it's within a point right now but
with 24 delegates the results there are
only going to influence the total count
to some degree it's going to be you know
a fraction of marginal difference there
Joe Biden winning in Alabama Virginia
North Carolina Tennessee Arkansas
Oklahoma Minnesota Massachusetts and
Texas Bernie Sanders winning Vermont
Colorado Utah and California although
the exact margin there are still being
tallied and then as I mentioned in Maine
in Maine the counting is still going on
Michael Bloomberg did pick up delegates
he is now in a third / fourth place in
delegate numbers based on active active
candidates we will discuss that
Elizabeth Warren did very poorly
performing at the 20% level only in her
home state of Massachusetts where she
came in third place and much like
Michael Bloomberg Warren clearly has no
path to the nomination at this point in
time when she gets out he's increasingly
a topic of concern says she's fighting
on to the following primaries based on a
fundraising email that she sent although
at the same time there is the idea that
she is reevaluating the campaign as is
Michael Bloomberg let's now look at the
delegate numbers every website has
slightly different numbers on this but
as of right now
according to the Associated Press the
delegate count is Biden four five three
and Bernie three eight - that's a 71
delegate lead for Joe Biden and we'll
we'll discuss in a moment why that is
important and then you see Warren and
Michael Bloomberg 50th and 44th place 50
delegates and 44 delegates respectively
one thing I was paying attention to that
tells us a lot about momentum and this
is really entering the analysis of
what's to come because there are a lot
of people saying this is over for Bernie
and there are a lot of people saying
this is the beginning of the fight for
Bernie and
a lot of Delegates still out there which
is of course completely true when we
look at the polling and compare it to
the results if candidates do better than
the polling it's a signal that they're
carrying pent-up momentum with them
including into future elections and
that's what we need to look at and when
we compare the results to the polling
what you see are good numbers for Joe
Biden again I'm just the messenger if
you look at many of these States Joe
Biden won by a larger margin than the
polling so as an example in Alabama
Biden won by 47 he was projected to win
by 25 Biden overperformed the polls by
22 Arkansas Biden overperformed by 5
California where Bernie won Bernie
underperformed by 3 in Colorado where
Bernie won
Bernie underperformed by 1 Massachusetts
Warren and Bernie were slated to to win
one or the other
Biden won by 7 over-performing
everything if you look at for example
Minnesota a Biden was supposed to lose
by 5 he won by 9 that's a plus 14 and as
you go down the list you find that Biden
overperformed basically every state and
Bernie underperformed basically every
state even Utah and Vermont where Bernie
won underperformed the polls by 8 and by
12 so the numbers are not particularly
good for Bernie Sanders sometimes when
you look forward you have to look at
what regions are left to vote so let's
talk about that going forward yes there
are plenty of Delegates out there yes
71 delegates as a margin Bernie Sanders
could very easily overcome in just one
night of voting but the question is
where is it going to happen and there
are all sorts of hot takes about this
it's not over Bernie's in it and they're
absolutely right Bernie can win it but
the window closes unless we can figure
out exactly where Bernie
win it because if you add up the
momentum meaning a lot of people saw Joe
Biden's reversal yesterday and I predict
Biden support will only grow from this
point forward to if you look at the
remaining big states they are not good
states for Bernie Sanders example
Florida has Biden plus 22 and that's two
hundred and nineteen delegates that's a
real problem for Bernie unless he
reverses it New York is going to be
closer for sure there's no recent
polling but it could be roughly a
three-way split between Biden and Bernie
and Bloomberg if Bloomberg gets out
Biden likely wins New York but again if
it's a roughly even split that helps
Biden in the delegate math because it
just maintains his lead we look at
Michigan the latest poll in Michigan has
Biden ahead Georgia is a big one with a
hundred and five delegates and Biden's
been ahead there since day one there's a
question mark around Ohio we don't have
any recent polls there and lastly if
Bloomberg does get out and Warren does
not he's reportedly reevaluating his
campaign today it's not clear what Biden
is doing if Bloomberg's out and Warren's
in that is even more support that's
going to go from Bloomberg to Biden and
that could be the nail in Bernie's
coffin that's the way the numbers are
looking right now so I'm here to tell
you
Bernie has a path and it is a steep
uphill path and it's getting to be very
similar to in 2016 and what I don't want
to participate in are these completely
out-of-this-world hypotheticals where
you had I'm not even going to name the
people a lot of them don't even really
have shows anymore their online presence
has gone away anyway so you wouldn't
even recognize the names but they were
there were all sorts of people in 2016
when it was very clear that it was over
for Bernie insisting not only that
Bernie had a shot but the Bernie had the
most likely shot I'm not going to do
that this is bad for Bernie he has a
path it depends on a reversal of
momentum it depends on changes happening
in the dynamics for this race this is
always a tough situation it happened in
2016 as well when I can't in good faith
come to you and tell you
lies or blow smoke up your whatever when
I do I am NOT a campaign spokesperson
right this is a well-orchestrated
reversal by the Democratic Party
it took 96 hours to rocket Joe Biden
into the position of now being the
favorite to win this thing and the
important thing that I want to get into
because with the numbers are the numbers
and I'm telling you what they are the
polls in upcoming states are what they
are what I want to talk about is should
this be considered a wake up call to the
progressive movement and if so what kind
and that's what I want to talk about
next MSNBC host Chris Matthews has had a
terrible week or 10 days and he is now
abruptly quit on live television last
night claiming he's retiring to clear a
path for the younger generation
coincidentally happening after two of
the most embarrassing on-air Fiasco's of
his career combined with sexual assault
sexual harassment allegations let's
first look at Chris Matthews quitting
then we'll look at what led up to it and
discuss whether we believe his
explanation the explanation does
reference the sexual harassment
allegations against him let me start
with my headline tonight I'm retiring
this is the last hard ball at MSNBC and
obviously this isn't for lack of
interest in politics as you can tell
I've loved every minute of my 20 years
as host of hardball
every morning I read the papers and I'm
gung ho to get to work not many people
have had this privilege I love working
with my producers and the discussions we
have over how to report the news and I
love having this connects with you the
good people who watch I've learned who
you are bumping into you on the sidewalk
or at waiting at an airport and say
hello you're like me I hear it from your
kids and grandchildren who say my dad
loves you or my grandmother loves you my
husband watched it till the end
well after conversation with MSNBC I
decided tonight will be my last hardball
so let me tell you why the younger
generation is out there ready to take
the reins we see them in politics in the
media and fighting for their causes they
are improving the workplace we're
talking here about better standards than
we grew up with fair standards a lot of
it has to do with how we talk to each
other
compliments on a woman's appearance that
some men including me might have once
incorrectly thought we're okay we're
never okay not then is certainly not
today and for making such comments in
the past I'm sorry so he says it's time
there's a younger generation coming
things are changing it's my time but he
does reference those allegations against
him from women of sexual harassment and
he does apologize for it but there's
more to this story because the day that
Jewish candidate Bernie Sanders won the
Nevada caucus Matthew said it was like
the Nazis invading France take a look
I'm reading last night about the fall of
France in the summer of 1940 and the
general renault calls up Churchill and
says it's over insurance is a hot can it
be you got the greatest army in Europe
how could it be over he said it's over
so I had that print suppressed feeling I
can't be as wild as Carville but he is
damn smart and I think he's damn right
on this one that led to calls for his
resignation and he apologized for saying
that then this past weekend Chris
Matthews got black politicians mixed up
mistaking black Republican senator Tim
Scott for black Democratic challenger
Jamie Harrison and it was just as
cringe-worthy as you imagine Jamie I see
you standing next to the guy you're
gonna beat right there maybe maybe maybe
Lindsey Graham Scott Sims guy Jamie
who's that that's Tim Scott Oh big
mistake mistaken identity sir sorry tell
me how you gonna be done and then the
cherry on top yes as Chris Matthews
alluded to comments to women that he has
made he did indeed get accused of sexual
harassment this week as well so Chris
Matthews goes out quickly there were
countless calls for him to resign and he
is immediately retiring a sort of
practical question who replaces him we
don't know there are reports that MSNBC
has been speaking to Shepard Smith who
left Fox News months ago I guess it
can't have been a year probably six
months ago I don't remember time is a
weird
in the Trump era Shep Smith left Fox
News after very public disagreements
with other hosts and with the Trump
propaganda machine and there are
discussions about could Shep Smith maybe
have a role to play in the future of
MSNBC so that's the story merely a quick
update with so much going on today it's
Super Tuesday so many other things I
don't want to dwell on this story much
more now but very quickly after three
very bad public incidents - on air one
of us sexual harassment allegations
Chris Matthews out at MSNBC I don't
think a lot of people in my audience are
particularly torn up over Chris Matthews
leaving but if I am wrong indeed let me
know one of the great tragedies of the
Trump administration is that almost
everything rather than mostly everything
is pure politics it's just sport its
wins and losses it's blame and credit
and this applies as well to the cool
virus dance party as some people
suggested we call it to avoid D
monetization for talking about it and
Donald Trump is now blaming the Obama
administration for the Trump
administration's response to the virus
check this out one of the things that
we've learned is that the u.s. is barely
doing any testing for it if you're not
sick enough to have to be hospitalized
in many cases even if you're suspected
of having it having the symptoms you
often aren't tested and the effect of
this of course is that the reported
number of cases in the United States is
likely drastically understating the
number of real cases and if you don't
get a positive test result and you
actually do have it you are more likely
to go out in public
possibly infect others if you think you
don't have it then someone who knows
that they have it and is more likely to
go may go home and self-quarantine
Donald Trump is blaming the lack of
testing on Barack Obama take a look at
this just want to add like my
and to go a little bit further the Obama
administration made a decision on
testing and that turned out to be very
detrimental to what we're doing and we
undid that decision a few days ago so
that the testing can take place in a
much more accurate and rapid fashion
that was the decision we disagreed with
I don't think we would have made it but
for some reason it was made but we've
undone that decision also when people
come in from certain areas we're doing
checks not only at the site of takeoff
but at the site of landing so when they
land in our country we'll also do this
if the planes are leaving from certain
destinations so nobody in the room
seemingly with any idea what Donald
Trump is talking about a decision Obama
made and Trump undid it so a reporter
did the right thing and followed up and
said what what rule are you talking
about what is this about Obama now and
Mike Pence who's leading this entire
fiasco says oh yeah yeah yeah FDA
jurisdiction something something Obama
error rule that you have changed
regarding this virus well let's talk
about it we could talk about Bob
Redfield you might speak about the last
administration asserted FDA jurisdiction
over testing and the development of
tests like this above President changed
that on Saturday so that now as I spoke
to several governors this morning states
now have the ability to actually conduct
the coronavirus test and state Labs
university laboratories inhibits and
that that's because of the change the
president authorized right because of
obama states couldn't test or is it they
couldn't develop tests or with
laboratories you know what is it
universities
this is gaslighting donald trump
disbanded the pandemic response team
donald trump gutted funding to the cdc
donald trump resisted treating this
seriously for weeks and not if not
months and continues to do so and as far
as the claim about the FDA and aid to
Republican senator Lamar Alexander said
the Obama administration didn't do
anything
Obama proposed giving the FDA
a more oversight over some tests it
didn't go through the truth that Donald
Trump won't tell you is that his CDC
made a mistake they tried to create
their own tests instead of accepting the
test that's been made available by the
World Health Organization the CDC test
failed and now we're in a situation
where we don't even know how many cases
we have it almost takes some skill some
creativity or at least some malignant
narcissism to make this even some how
about Barack Obama
you know blaming the last guy for debt
or unemployment numbers it's at least
theoretically viable blaming the last
guy three years into your presidency for
your response to a pandemic threat would
only work on I guess exactly the types
of people who think Donald Trump is
doing a great job I would go further
weren't the testing forms in Hillary's
emails which she bleached an acid-wash
to offer for private server let go even
further and meanwhile they say we don't
want to politicize this the way
Democrats are politicizing the virus and
while we're on this topic don't forget
how the anti Obama people in 2014 were
reacting to Obama's handling of Ebola
which of course ended up not becoming a
global pandemic and about which all
conversation simply stopped the day
after the 2014 midterms Republicans
would have had you think we had a
domestic crisis on our hands in the
United States thanks to Barack Obama on
Ebola right up until the day of the 2014
midterms at which point we barely heard
a word about Ebola again but they don't
want what's going on now politicized by
Democrats it's pathetic it's disgusting
and it's leading to more people being
sick this is not a joke
this is not did I increase or decrease
the deficit this is life and death and
it's absolutely disgusting